المتحدث باسم الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه بعدين سكيبسكي ان روسيا عدلت
في قيادتها العسكريه وانهت المرحله الاولى
من التعبئه وبدات تقدم نحو اوكرانيا
استعدادا لهجوم قوي اشاره الى ان روسيا
بامكانها تعبئه الاف الجنود لكن تنقصها
المعدات وفقولها
المرحله الاولى من التعبئه وخلال هذه
الفتره تم انشاء احتياطيه تعبئه وتشكيل
اقسام واعدادها الان بداوا جميعا في
التقدم الى الحدود مع اوكرانيا وتمت اعاده
تجميع القوات ويستعدون لهجوم قوي
حنا كاترين مرحبا بك معنا اذا كيف على
الانسان اكثر من مسؤوله منهم الرئيس هنالك
تحذير منه قوي روسي وتعويل كبير على ما تم
ااه الاشاره اليه من دبابات امريكيه
والمانيا
نعم محمد بدايه اريد ان اشير الى انه منذ
دقائق ونحن ننتظر على الهواء دوره الصفرات
والانذار في اكياف واعلن في عموم اوكرانيا
الانذار الجوي بعد رصد طائره طائره روسيه
من نوع مجدي 31 محمله بصواريخ فنجال
انطلقت من احد المطارات في
بيلاروسيا اما بالنسبه
للاخبار الوارده عن الموقفين الامريكي
والالماني بشان الدبابات ابرامز
فبالنسبه لاوكرانيا هي تنظر بعين الترقب
وتنتظر القرارات العمليه بهذا الشان
انطلاقه من رؤيتها بان هذه الدبابات هي
اساسيه ومهمه في تغيير المعادله على الارض
في المعارك وكذلك في تعزيز القدرات
القتاليه الميدانيه للجيش الاوكراني فما
قاله الرئيس الاوكراني بالامس تعليقا على
هذه الاخبار مفاده كفى نقاشات واتخذوا
القرارات بهذا الشان هو قال ان هناك
الكثير من الجهود والوعود والحديث عن قرب
تزويد اوكرانيا بالدبابات الثقيله ولكن
قال نحن بن اللي انا اا ننتظر رؤيه الواقع
هذا ما هو المهم وانه عندما نرى ثقل
القرارات همم بشكل حقيقي عندها سوف نشكركم
على جهودكم وعلى هذه القرارات هذا الامر
همم يعيدنا الى ما كانت اوكرانيا تركز
عليه بشكل اساسي في الايام والاسابيع
الماضيه وهو يرتكز على نقاط ثلاث محمد
اولا موضوع عدد الدبابات التي تنتظر
اوكرانيا ان تحصل عليها الرئيس الاوكراني
وقبله وزير الدفاع وغيرهم ايضا دائما
يركزون على ان اوكرانيا بحاجه لمئات عده
من هذه الدبابات بحيث ان 10 دبابات او
خمسه 10 دبابه او حتى 20 لا تكفيها في هذه
المعركه اذا النقطه الاولى هي العدد
النقطه الثانيه تتعلق بمساله الوقت عام من
الوقت وهو اساسيا في هذا الموضوع هذه
الدبابات بحاجه الى ان يتدرب عليها الجنود
الاوكرانيون وهذا ما يتطلب وقتا بينما
هناك معلومات تتحدث عنها اوكرانيا عن قرب
همم ان روسيا هجوم واسعه نطاق على على
اوكرانيا وانها تستعد لذلك مع بدايه فصل
الربيع
وهمم بدايه الصيف ايضا وبشكل اكثر تحديدا
بين شهرين شباط واذار اذا امام اوكرانيا
شهر او شهر ونصف فقط من اجل ان تتدرب على
هذه الدبابات وبالنسبه لها هذا الامر لا
يحتمل مزيدا من التاجيل اما النقطه
الثالثه والاساسيه ايضا والتي لاحظنا ان
السلطات الاوكرانيه تحرص على تضمينها في
كافه مواقفها هو ان همم اوكرانيا تسعى الى
طماط خلفائها المترددين بشان تزويدها بهذه
الدبابات الثقيله وتقول او على لسان
رئيسها تحديدا تقول انها لن تستخدمه هذه
الدبابات ابدا للهجوم على روسيا بل هي في
موقع الدفاع حتى ان وزير الدفاع سبق ان
قدمناه بان اوكرانيا سوف تضمن ان تستخدمه
هذه الدبابات بشكل المسؤول و بشكل حصريا
لتحرير ما تسميها اوكرانيا اراضيها
مؤقتا بما فيها شبه جزيره القرم اذا ترقب
وانتظار في اوكرانيا محمد للقرارات
العمليه وليس فقط للنقاشات التي حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تحسم بشكل واضح ما يتعلق بتزويد
اوكرانيا بهذه الدبابات من عدمه شكرا
جزيلا لك